make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
ok so I think it's safe to say that you
guys absolutely loved the spawn
Armageddon video that we did spawns war
against God and Satan begins a lot of
the guys really seemed like what about
that title though right but like it's
it's legit right like what do you guys
think
right because you guys really seem to
like it so in this one where this this
is actually technically part of the
seconds of the the second part of the
story because we're splitting into three
sections maybe three or four sections
but this one I decided to do on its own
and the reason why is because this is
the origin of God Satan and everything
how it all came into existence which is
a cool thing right because it kind of
expands and builds in the spawn mythos
in a really really cool way so in the
last video that we did we basically had
this great big huge revelation that the
twin children of Wanda and Terry are
basically Jake and Katie that Jake
himself was God atleast it was revealed
that he was God which begged the
question who was Katie and I'm sure a
lot of you guys have probably figured it
out by now
but that's kind of what goes on right
you know with this kind of revelation
here you know Jake almost sort of gets
carried away with himself he's like all
my memories are coming back now now I
remember who I am
I'm God and the way that the way that
God operates here is interesting because
you would expect that Jake acting and
kind of like this this really violent
manner as a child or something like that
it's maybe just like him being a crazy
kid but as soon as his memories came
back of him being God he would go to
become more enlightened he'd become more
caring he'd be a very benign person like
I'm sorry my children for the way I
conducted myself that kind of a thing no
he's a dick like juice it's nuts you
know he's like I am God I created all of
you guys out of mud and you guys all
should bow before me you know and it's
just like extreme arrogance in hubris
right and so in response to that
Katie's memories all begin flowing back
and then Katie comes to the realization
that she's Satan and it just kind of
like wow you know in there from there
like they both get pissed they're like
who stuck us in these bodies right like
who put us in this place and so in
response to that God basically tells
Sarah kill spawn right like take him out
and then we'll worry about everybody
else later you know because initially
they say it like you have to kneel down
right like kneel down to us bow down to
us and at the end of the day spawns like
no like I'm not I'm not going to you
know like like give us all the
information hand like no I'm not going
to write as far as like I'm not doing
that you're crazy if you think I am and
so in response gods like make him talk
so zero goes to get into a conflict with
spawn and it's kind of interesting right
because were the two of them go and they
clash you know as soon as there as soon
as their weapons touch they stop right
and they're separated and when that
happens God and Satan begin to get
pissed off if Satan's like you know you
don't have the right to do any of this
and this this being is like but I do
though because like I'm your mother I'm
the one who created you and that's when
we start to get this this really cool
origin because immediately the mouths of
Satan in God are sealed shut right so
whoever this being is is more powerful
than they are seals their mouth shut
they can't talk and then says it's time
all of you learned the truth and so what
we end up finding out here is that when
spawn starts talking to you this person
known as mother what she says or is it's
not really a she it kind of transcends
genders but what mother ends up saying
here is there was essentially me right
like I created everything I created all
the gods that are in existence I have a
whole bunch of different faces and
you've met me countless times before you
met me when I was disguised as Kali the
goddess of destruction you met me when I
was disguised as the man of miracles I
stand beyond all gods that exist inside
your universe right I am the God of all
gods and it's kind of crazy because what
mother ends up saying is like I'm the
creator and destroyer of worlds
I created everything in this universe
and this is not the only planet that
houses God every planet around this
entire universe has gods you know every
planet in every single solar system in
every galaxy and every universe has its
own gods and as people lay worshipped -
but of all the gods that I've created
over the course of my entire existence
Satan and God as you see him are the
most dissapointing right and that's
what's kind of crazy about it is because
it's like initially you know like mother
basically treats them exactly like
children right then when they were
initially created that there was kinda
like some bickering and some squabbling
but as time went on their bickering and
squabbling turned into full-scale
warfare against each other but something
happened that ultimately mother didn't
expect that God created mankind but the
funny thing about it is is that that
todd mcfarlane really grabs this notion
of like how humanity exists now and
walls in an in a perfectly genius way
right because according to biblical
scripture depending on how you look at
it something it literally some don't but
it's kind of an ongoing war between God
and Satan right that God created
humanity and God loves humanity and that
kind of a thing and that Satan is always
trying to trick humanity and then bring
humanity down to its level right you
know that kind of bolster his army and
gods trying to bolster his army and the
two of them are gonna have like a final
war something like that but in you know
true biblical scripture or at least if
you're new test
God's not like out to get you like I'm
just looking for reasons to draw a line
through your name instead of under it
that's Old Testament stuff right but
like New Testament is a wholly different
beast but the way this picture is
painted here is that for the most part
like it's kind of an ongoing war between
the two but Satan is always trying to
grab humanity right like always trying
to trick humanity at the end of the day
God is doing his thing but like Satan is
always trying to find a way to get
humanity to his side and that's what
makes it kind of nuts is because for all
their grandeur and for all their pomp
and circumstance because of everything
that that's that's going on here because
of this war between the two which is
really kind of depicted as Old Testament
you know Scripture more or less that
essentially mother came along and said
enough is enough I've had enough of
watching you guys fight each other I've
had enough of you guys ago when the war
between heaven and hell this is not what
I intended when I created you and so as
a result of that mother basically puts
them in a state of suspended animation
and then mother shows up in the form of
Jesus Christ and that's where you get
Jesus is kind of like this sort of
Savior right this super benign guy who's
like hey dude is like hey peeps you know
like gods cool man like you know it's
cool don't be dicks to each other
don't burn each other at the snake
different things like that mother
appeared in a way that was design to
basically tell people here's how you're
supposed to function right you're
supposed to truly care about the other
people around you think more about them
than you do about yourself if somebody
will think more about you than they do
about themselves right everybody will
care about everybody else now the
reality is that if everybody cared about
everybody else indiscriminately the
world couldn't function but the fact
remains that despite the efforts of
mother to curtail humanity that in the
end it was too late
right the nature of humanity was set in
stone that people were continuing to
ward over which religion was actually
right who was on the right side
essentially and so that's why mother
basically says even after appearing in
the form of Jesus people still kept
twisting up my viewpoints they kept
twisting up how it was all supposed to
be and using religion more or less as a
weapon to further their own personal
agendas whether its entire armies and
kingdoms or just some crazy preacher
down south somewhere regardless of the
situation people kept twisting things
out well then the question is why our
God and Satan in the bodies of children
and the response of her is because I
thought that in forcing them to be
reborn in the form of humanity that they
would learn to appreciate what it meant
to be human they would learn to
appreciate what it meant to be human
beings but the reality is that never
changed that never stopped you know even
though they didn't know who they were
they still had this extremely an
extraordinary
of power and the result was at the
various battles and in skirmishes they
were getting into you we're literally
causing all kinds of problems around the
world and so then it turns of the idea
that eventually Al Simmons died and
that's where mother saw her chance to
intervene yet again when Al Simmons died
there were 6,000 other people that died
in the same hour that he did and so in
response to that realizing that mal
Bojan is one of the many hell lords that
exist under Satan was essentially
bolstering his army as a means to take
on heaven that mother saw this as an
opportunity to create someone that could
essentially be her personal soldier more
or less she doesn't really say it in so
many words but that's more or less what
spawn is that spawn is someone who
doesn't really follow the follow the
beliefs of God or Satan that he does his
own thing right he walks his own path
and that's what makes him so unique is
that mother saw this and said okay in
that case spawn can be used right and to
kind of allow this Armageddon to take
place allow the end of all things to
take place now this is kind of the
difference between Armageddon or like
the rapture in the judeo-christian sense
and like how things are going down here
right and your day'll christianity the
rapture is really nothing more than like
the stories of the faithful being taken
back to heaven right you have the seven
bowls of God's wrath and you got the
seven trumpets of the Apocalypse and so
on so forth the plagues return to earth
and me all that kind of crazy stuff
basically everything goes belly-up is
more or less what it is but it's this
notion of like the taken those who are
faithful being whisked away to heaven
before it all begins and then those who
are unfaithful being left behind and
then then it kind of breaks down based
on different stories that you read and
so on but here the Armageddon is tried
and true Armageddon the destruction of
everything presumably everything except
for a mother and we'll find out how all
this this plays out later on but it
really is the end of everything
presumably the end of God the end of
Satan the end of humanity the end of the
end of the whole damn thing right like
that's basically what it is the whole
kit and caboodle all gets the boot and
that's what's kind of nuts here is
because following that because
Armageddon has begun because the war of
God and Satan has to play out in order
for Armageddon to take place the
question of spawn is well then why don't
you just fix everything if you create a
God and Satan then get it together fix
God fix Satan stop making him like stop
letting him be dicks to each other get
Humanity on the right path then there's
no need for me anymore and I can just
live in the afterlife I can go to heaven
and just experience some peace house
bowels like just let me live man just
let me go and and the response of mother
is I can't and the reason why is because
I as mother and beholden to laws of the
universe because I made them what's the
point of how
laws if I just break them willy-nilly I
don't break them because they not
they're not meant to be broken
what kind of a role model would I be if
I create and break my own rules
but then say nobody else can at that
point you just comes down to you being a
being a jerk right just being a dick you
know it so at the end of the day you
know what you end up having is God and
Satan being sent back to their
respective places right God is sent back
to heaven Satan is sent back to health
but when God shows up here along with
Zahra he basically looks at all the
other Seraphim right all the other
angels who have been here and is
basically said you guys have all been
slacking off apparently like some folks
from Hell managed to break in and kill a
whole bunch of my army you know Satan is
is doing his whole thing like what have
you guys been doing all this time
rightly the guy's just been like resting
on your laurels sitting around watching
the view is that what you guys have been
doing like just kind of just just really
really hard on them right and and so in
response that he's like you know with
basically almost all of our forces
dwindled the time now comes to take the
faithful those individuals who worshiped
me but didn't really know what I was
about believes that I was like a kind
and caring God it doesn't matter bring
them right so like the rapture begins
essentially and at that moment that's
when we switch back over to spawn and
over to Wanda and Terry and all these
guys now mothers still there and mothers
watching it all unfold but what you end
up having spawn and Terry you know
really Terry who's just like screaming
and yelling and Swan over everything for
Wanda it's just too much to handle it's
more than she can cope with and so what
Wanda ends up doing is basically taking
a pistol out and in walking all the way
up to the master bedroom nobody realizes
she's there walking all the way up to
the master bedroom taking the taking the
pistol pointing it to herself and then
pulling the trigger that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
cliffhangers if you are new here to come
this explained make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
I want to say thank you to all of the
new patrons who have joined patreon.com
slash comics explained I want to give a
shout out to Henry young - Elias G David
J s Jacob H been John H Jason see Austin
s Austin H James O kristymatt in Jeff
our Joey em Steven Z sloth-like lu-david
see John H lean and mean that guy asked
questions all the time Adam Cajun gnosis
916 I want to say thank you to all of
you all this list is growing all the
time leave it to the patreon
[Music]